bonjour à tous je suis Pauline CRPI je
travaille à la Merise où je suis
directrice adjointe et chargée du jeune
public aujourd'hui je vais vous parler
du spectacle l'aprèsmidi d'un Phone et
vous donner trois raisons de venir le
[Musique]
voir la première raison c'est que c'est
un spectacle absolument spectaculaire
c'est un balai de sac plastique animé
par des ventilateurs on a jamais vu ça
la deuxième c'est un spectacle
absolument merveilleux e où on retrouve
la musique de Claude dubusy l'après-midi
d'un faone et enfin la troisième c'est
parce que c'est notre coup de cœur à la
meurce pour le jeune public je pense que
c'est un spectacle que tout le monde
devrait voir à la fois les enfants et
les plus grands voilà c'était mes trois
raisons pour aller voir l'après-midi
d'un faone le dimanche 19 novembre à 15h
à la
[Musique]
Merise